Okay. Hallo, schon guten Tag.
So, guten Tag.
Ja, mein Name ist, ich bin Frau Dr. Shahi.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzärztin tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen die
Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja. Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir, ja.
Okay, okay. Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen.
Erst brauche ich Ihre persönliche Daten, dann gehen wir mit Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden durch, okay?
Ja, okay.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Nadia Winter.
Nadia Winter. Okay, das ist sehr deutlich, aber können Sie kurz buchstabieren, damit
ich nicht falsch schreibe?
Ja, der Vorname ist N-A-D-J-A.
Nadia. Okay.
Und Winter ist wie Sommer, W-I-N-T-E-R, Winter, wie die Jahreszeit.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Winter?
Ich bin noch 46 Jahre alt.
46, okay, ziemlich jung. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8.07.79.
79, okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Winter?
Ich bin 1,67.
Okay, und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege so 71 Kilo ungefähr.
71 Kilo. Okay, Frau Winter, was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ja, also heute Morgen hatte ich mit einem so heftiges Herzrasen,
da habe ich richtig Angst bekommen.
Und ja, mir geht es eigentlich schon seit einer ganzen Weile
irgendwie nicht so gut.
Und zwar bin ich eigentlich so unruhig, ich bin so zitterig,
ich kann nachts nicht schlafen.
Und ja, ich bin unheimlich nervös und reizbar.
Und heute Morgen dieses Gefühl, dass das Herz mir wirklich
bis zu den Ohren rausschlägt, ja.
Das war sehr beängstigend.
Und ja, es ist wirklich was Merkwürdiges passiert.
Ich bin zweimal in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen,
war ich zweimal ganz kurz ohnmächtig.
Okay.
Ja, das hat mir jetzt schon ein bisschen schreck gemacht,
aber heute Morgen eben diese Herzgeschichte,
da habe ich mir gedacht, jetzt gehst du doch endlich mal ins Krankenhaus.
Okay, wie vielmal waren Sie ohnmächtig?
Das ist zweimal passiert.
Aber immer nur ganz kurz, ja.
Okay, sind Sie gestürzt, wenn Sie ohnmächtig waren?
Nein, das war, Gott sei Dank ist mir eigentlich nichts passiert.
Also das eine Mal war zu Hause und das andere war bei der Arbeit,
da habe ich aber gerade Pause machen können
und habe eigentlich am Tisch gesessen und war dann nur kurz weg, ja.
Okay, fällt Ihnen vielleicht Gedächtnisstörungen?
Das wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Also wie gesagt von dieser Ohnmacht, das kann ich natürlich nicht sagen.
Also diese zwei Minuten fehlen mir natürlich, klar.
Aber ansonsten glaube ich nicht, dass mein Gedächtnis besonders schlecht ist.
Okay, okay. Und haben Sie jetzt immer noch Herzlosen?
Können Sie es durchhalten?
Ich bin wieder weg, aber das hat mir solche Angst gemacht,
dass ich gedacht habe, Mensch jetzt muss doch mal was passieren, ja.
Haben Sie vorher auch solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, aber also...
Also das ist der erste Mal, diese Unruhe?
Mit dem Herzen, das ist das erste Mal, sonst, ja.
Sonst wäre ich sicherlich früher gekommen.
Aber die Unruhe habe ich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile,
das merke ich, dass das nicht so gut ist.
Und, ja, was mir auch aufgefallen ist,
ich habe in letzter Zeit wirklich sehr, sehr oft Durchfälle.
Und habe auch tatsächlich schon ein bisschen Gewicht verloren.
Ich meine, da ist man ja nie so traurig, wenn man ein bisschen Gewicht verliert.
Aber ja, also ich versuche ja ganz normal zu essen.
Und diese ständigen Durchfälle ist natürlich auch ein bisschen nervig.
Ok, seit wann haben Sie Durchfälle?
Ja, das ist jetzt auch schon so in den letzten Wochen so.
Also in den letzten zwei bis drei Wochen nehme ich an.
Nee, eigentlich schon ein bisschen länger.
Also das ist nicht jedes Mal, aber immer mal wieder, ja.
Ok, schon länger.
Ok, haben Sie auch Bauchkrämpfe?
Naja, mit dem Durchfall habe ich gelegentlich auch mal Bauchkrämpfe.
Aber die Schmerzen sind nicht das Hauptproblem, nee.
Ok, also Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Schlafstörungen haben.
Also haben Sie Einschlafstörungen oder Durchschlafstörungen?
Ja, also zunächst mal fällt mir das Einschlafen schwer.
Und wenn ich dann mal aufwache in der Nacht, weil irgendwas ist,
weil ein Geräusch ist oder weil ich vielleicht auf die Toilette muss oder so,
dann komme ich wieder zurück ins Bett und kann überhaupt nicht wieder einschlafen.
Dann bin ich ganz unruhig.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme mit Atemnot bemerkt?
Nee, das habe ich eigentlich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ok, haben Sie Husten?
Husten habe ich nicht, nee.
Mit der Atemnuss glaube ich alles ok.
Ok, sehr toll, ganz toll.
Haben Sie sich fiebrig gefühlt?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber fiebrig habe ich mich eigentlich nicht gefühlt.
Ok, also haben Sie solche Schüttelfrostnachschweiß bemerkt?
Nee, das nicht.
Also mir ist zwar eher warm, aber so richtig schwitzen tue ich eigentlich nicht.
Fühle ich mich eigentlich auch nicht.
Ok, Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie in letzter Zeit wegen dem Durchfall ein bisschen abgenommen haben.
Wissen Sie wie viel Kilogramm Sie abgenommen haben und in welcher Zeitraum?
Ja, also das sind so ungefähr drei Kilo, die ich runter habe.
Und ja, das ist vielleicht so ein Vierteljahr.
In letztes Jahr, in einem Jahr?
In einem Vierteljahr, in drei Monaten.
Ok, und wie ist es mit Ihrem Appetit?
Eigentlich habe ich schon Appetit.
Und auch in den letzten drei Monaten hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert?
Nee, eigentlich würde ich nicht sagen.
Sogar, dass ich sehr gut esse, würde ich behaupten.
Ok, fällt Ihnen also irgendwelche, gibt es bestimmte Lebensmittel, die den Durchfall auslöst?
Haben Sie sowas bemerkt?
Das könnte ich jetzt gar nicht sagen.
Also eigentlich ist das immer wieder, ich kann das nicht irgendwie einem Lebensmittel zuordnen.
Dass ich sage, was weiß ich, immer wenn ich Kohl esse oder so, dann kriege ich Durchfall.
Oder immer wenn ich Paprika esse, kriege ich Durchfall.
Nee, das kommt immer wieder, egal was ich esse.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Nee, da habe ich zum Glück keine Probleme.
Ok, Frau Winter, haben Sie Bekannte vor Erkrankungen, chronische Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Blutkrankheit.
Ja, ich quäle mich tatsächlich schon seit vielen Jahren rum mit Endometriose.
Endometriose.
Ja, und das ist natürlich oft mit Beschwerden, wenn Sie nach Bauchschmerzen oder Bauchkrämpfen fragen,
da habe ich natürlich dann hin und wieder meine Probleme.
Und das habe ich schon seit ich 18 bin eigentlich.
Und ja, aus dem Grund nehme ich Minolet.
Das soll das so ein bisschen reduzieren, die Beschwerden.
Ok, wie heißt die Medikamente nochmal?
Das ist eine Pille, Minolet heißt die.
Minolit.
Das ist eigentlich ein Verwütungs...
Also ein Antik...
Wie nennt man das?
Also Kontrazeptivum.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie man das...
Minolet.
Minolet, ok, habe verstanden.
Und wie viel Milgramm nehmen Sie ein?
Ich weiß nicht wie die dosiert ist.
Man nimmt ja jeden Tag seine Tablette.
Ok.
Sind Sie schon mal gesund, welche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein, also...
Bisher war ich immer gesund, ja.
Ok, ok, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Naja, als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Und dann, ja, so mit 17 ist der Blinddarm rausgekommen, ja.
Ok.
Und wann war die Mandelentfernung Operation?
Da war ich, also gerade am Ende von der Grundschule, also so 10 Jahre alt ungefähr.
Ok.
Und mit 17 Jahren haben Sie gesagt, die...
Da war der Blinddarm, genau.
Ja, ok.
Frau Winter, bekommen Sie Ihre Wegelblutung regelmäßig?
Ja, natürlich so ein bisschen bedingt durch diese Pille, ne?
Ja.
Die sorgt ja dafür, dass der Zyklus regelmäßig...
Ja, Sie nehmen die Pille jeden Tag in der...
In der gleichen Zeit.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ok, ok.
Und, ok.
Kann es sein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Nein, das ist ausgeschlossen.
Ok.
Ich lebe mit einer Frau zusammen und habe keinen nennlichen Partner.
Insofern ist das nicht möglich, dass ich ein Kind bekomme.
Ok, sind Sie...
Also Sie sind ledig?
Ja, ich bin ledig, aber lebe mit einer Partnerin zusammen.
Ok, ok.
Und Sie haben kein Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder, nein.
Ok.
Und was sind Sie beruflich tätig?
Ich arbeite als Schuhverkäuferin.
Schuhverkäuferin?
Schuhverkäuferin, ja, genau.
Ok.
Da haben wir natürlich immer zu Beginn der Saison,
zu Beginn der Wintersaison und zu Beginn der Sommersaison.
Wenn es dann die neuen Modelle gibt, ist immer viel Arbeit.
Und wenn alle Leute ihre Garderobe ändern,
dann haben wir immer viel Betrieb, ja.
Und natürlich auch im Schlussverkauf, da ist auch immer viel los.
Ok.
Frau Winter, haben Sie außer die Pille
noch irgendwelche Medikamente,
die Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf einnehmen?
Also wenn ich das merke, dass ich so ganz unruhig bin
oder dass ich so das Gefühl habe,
heute Nacht kann ich überhaupt nicht einschlafen,
dann nehme ich wohl mal Baldrian-Tropfen.
Baldrian-Tropfen, ok.
Ich nehme aber jetzt nicht jeden Tag, ne?
Ok, das hilft aber Ihnen.
Ja, so ein bisschen was bringt es schon, ja.
Ok. Ist bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Also das Einzige, was ich weiß,
dass ich auf braunes Pflaster allergisch bin.
Braunes Pflaster, ok.
Und wie reagieren Sie dagegen?
Ja, dann kriege ich halt so rote Pickelchen auf der Haut,
da wo der Kleber ist, ne?
Ok.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten
gegen irgendwelche Lebensmitteln?
Nein, also wie gesagt,
bei dem Durchfall kann ich nicht sagen,
dass da irgendwas ist.
Nee, generell.
Also ich kann eigentlich alles essen.
Ok.
Super, toll.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Winter?
Ja, ich habe vor drei Jahren aufgehört mit dem Rauchen.
Da bin ich auch sehr stolz drauf, ja.
Aber ich habe eigentlich auch nie so furchtbar viel geraucht.
Ich habe eigentlich immer nur so
sechs Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Das war eigentlich mehr so aus Gesellschaft
mit den Kollegen oder so.
Aber jetzt seit drei Jahren eben
gar nicht mehr.
Ok. Und wie viele Jahre lang haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, das waren so zwölf Jahre.
Ok. Super, toll.
Ich glaube, dass Sie aufgehört haben.
Ja, da bin ich auch wirklich glücklich darüber, ja.
Frau Winter, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also
am Wochenende oder wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt
oder wenn es besonders gutes Essen gibt.
Also mal ein Glas Wein trinke ich schon ganz gerne, ja.
Ok. Und ich habe noch eine Frage.
Aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich an.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das habe ich nie probiert.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Wir müssen das vorstellen.
Ok. Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen faul,
aber doch.
Also im Sommer fahre ich sehr gerne mit dem Fahrrad.
Und ja, wenn wir im Urlaub sind,
dann spielen wir auch gerne mal Volleyball am Strand
oder so.
Aber dass ich jetzt nun regelmäßig Sport mache,
im Winter fällt mir das ein bisschen schwerer.
Manchmal mache ich so ein bisschen Gymnastik,
wenn ich merke, dass mir der Rücken weh tut oder so.
Aber dass ich jetzt nun so eine Sportkanone bin,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Ok. Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, geimpft bin ich natürlich, weil ich so viel Kontakt
mit anderen Menschen habe, ja.
Da gucke ich schon, dass ich regelmäßig alle Impfungen habe.
Ok. Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Im Ausland war ich, nein, schon lange nicht mehr.
Nein, ich habe schon lange keine große Urlaubsreise gemacht.
Ok.
Frau Winter, gibt es in Ihrer Familie
chronische Erkrankungen, von denen Sie wissen?
Ja, also meine Mutter,
die hat tatsächlich eine Darmerkrankung.
Darmerkrankung?
Ja, das heißt Morbus Crohn.
Das ist so eine, ja,
die hat immer wieder Probleme mit dem Darm.
Ok. Und Ihre Vater?
Ja, mein Vater,
der ist vor einem Jahr gestorben.
Der hat gelitten unter heftigen Gichtanschälen.
Der hat aber auch sehr viel Alkohol getrunken.
Und letztendlich hatte der eine Blutvergiftung.
Ja, daran ist er letztendlich gestorben, ja.
Ja, das tut mir leid. Wann hatte er gestorben?
Vor einem Jahr war das.
Ok. Haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Winter?
Ja, ich habe zwei Schwestern.
Ok. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, wir sehen uns nicht so oft,
aber eigentlich sind die gesund, ja.
Ok. Also soweit Sie wissen, leiden Sie
alle an chronischen Erkrankungen.
Nee, also so eine,
ich wüsste nicht, dass da irgendjemand was hat.
Ok. Frau Winter,
ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie auch Bauchkrämpfe?
Also ja, manchmal, wenn ich Durchfall habe,
habe ich halt ein bisschen Bauchkrämpfe
und halt im Rahmen dieser Endometriose.
Wenn ich meine Periode habe,
dann sind die Krämpfe schon
also auch ein bisschen mehr, ja.
Ok. Und wenn Sie Durchfall haben,
wie sieht Ihre Stuhl aus?
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl gesehen?
Blut ist da garantiert nicht drin.
Das ist halt alles, das ist halt alles
verdauertes Zeug und ja,
das ist halt wässriger als normal.
Ok.
Ok. Frau Winter, da sind die Fragen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen wollte.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Sie haben mich ja jetzt so viel
Sachen gefragt und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt,
was ist los und wo kommt dieses Herzrasen her
und auch diese komischen Unwahrtsanfälle?
Das ist ja ein bisschen bedrohliches Gefühl.
Das kann man sich ja irgendwie nicht erlauben
im Berufsleben und was kann man dagegen machen?
Das ist die Frage. Ja, ich verstehe,
dass Sie ein bisschen
Sorgen machen, dass Sie sich Sorgen machen.
Wir werden erst bestimmt
ein bisschen anstehen, was mit Ihnen los ist.
Aber dafür brauche ich noch ein bisschen
Geduld, damit ich mit meinen Oberärzten
sprechen kann.
Ich bitte Sie, im Wartezimmer ein bisschen
zu warten, dann komme ich wieder zurück.
Körperliche Untersuchungen und ein paar
Laboruntersuchungen Blut abzunehmen.
Laboruntersuchungen, ok.
Gut, dann warte ich jetzt im Wartezimmer.
Ja, und bis dann, Frau Winter.
Ok, das war's.
Wunderbar. Möchte noch jemand
irgendwas Zusätzliches wissen von der Frau Winter?
Ja, wir sehen
die Haare, Haut, Nägel aus.
Die Haare sind ein bisschen struppig.
Die Nägel,
die Nägel,
ich meine, bei der Arbeit
brechen die natürlich leicht mal ab.
Und ich muss die immer ziemlich kurz schneiden.
Aber, ja.
Gibt es noch andere Fragen?
Ich würde sagen, Sie haben sehr erschöpfend
abgefragt. Ja, da kommt was.
Herr Wichmann? Ja.
Könnten Sie bitte
struppig schreiben in den Chat?
Was soll ich schreiben?
Ihre Haare,
Ihre Haare, Charakter oder
Sie haben gesagt, meine Haare sind struppig.
Deine Haare sind ein bisschen struppig.
Das heißt, so ein bisschen frockig.
Ok, können Sie
Okay, danke.
Das ist aber eher auf den Augenblick
bezogen. So wie Sie jetzt tatsächlich aussehen.
Frau Wichmann,
ist Ihnen eine Hitzeunverträglichkeit
oder schlechtes vertragende Wärme
oder Kälte aufgefallen?
Ja, also jetzt
diese plötzliche Wärme jetzt,
dass es mit einmal so sehr warm geworden ist,
das konnte ich nicht so gut vertragen. Das stimmt ja.
Das ging mir zu schnell sozusagen.
Und haben Sie vielleicht bemerkt
eine Konzentrationsstörung?
Konzentrieren Sie sich?
Ja, also ich habe ja gesagt, so ein bisschen unruhig fühle ich mich.
Nervös.
Ja, aber so richtig schlimme Konzentrationsstörung.
Ich muss mich bei der Arbeit ja, muss ich jetzt auch
nicht so aufmerksam sein. Ich muss ja nicht irgendwelche
Listen vergleichen oder so.
Das läuft schon im Alltag.
Danke.
Möchte jemand noch was fragen? Aber Ihr Mikro ist nicht an.
Fühlen Sie sich nervös?
Und haben Sie das bemerkt? Stande Hände?
Ja, habe ich auch gesagt.
Dankeschön.
Struppig, ja. Dr. Puppi hat es gesagt. Genau.
Frau Doktor, sagen Sie Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Also, okay.
Ja, also wir fragen
erstmal ab, ob noch Fragen sind. Sonst, wie gesagt,
Sie können auch noch weiter überlegen.
Ja, jetzt kommt noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Hautveränderung?
Oder trockene Haut?
Ja, trockene Haut habe ich immer schon.
Also, ich muss immer kremen. Ja. Das ist aber nicht neu, ne?
Früher haben Sie Schiftruise-Probleme gehabt.
Was für Probleme?
Schiftruise-Unterfunktionen oder Oberfunktionen.
Da weiß ich nichts von.
Okay.
Kann es losgehen?
Ja, kann es losgehen.
Also, okay.
Hallo, Herr Doktor Oberärztin.
Ich habe eine neue
Patiente aufgenommen. Ich würde Sie gerne vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Unsere Patiente heißt Nadia Winter.
Frau Nadia Winter ist
46 Jahre alt, ist 1,67 m hoch
und wiegt 71 kg.
Frau Winter habe heute Morgen
ein heftiges Herzrasen.
Das war das erste Mal.
Vorher hatte sie so etwas.
Sie hatte berichtet, dass das das erste Mal
so etwas ist.
Außerdem fügte sie hin zu,
dass sie in den letzten 2-3 Wochen
zweimal ohnmächtig
zweimal ihre Bewusstsein verloren hat.
Die Bewusstsein habe
ungefähr 2 Minuten gedauert.
Die Bewusstlosigkeit.
Ja, die Bewusstlosigkeit
hat 2 Minuten gedauert.
Außerdem beschwert sie
über Einschlafstörungen und Nervosität.
Sie leidet unter
Durchfälle und
...
Ein fachbegriff?
Das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Sie leidet unter Diarrhohe
in den letzten Wochen.
Sie hat auch gelegentlich Bauchkrämpfe.
Sie berichtet, dass sie in den letzten 3 Monaten
ungefähr wegen dieser Diarrhohe
3 kg abgenommen hat.
Und die
Blut im Stuhl
habe sie nicht gesehen.
Und die Fragen nach Atemnot, Husten, Fieber.
Also Nachtschweißschüttelfrost wurde verneint.
Und ihre Appetit
sei normal.
Und Frau Winter leider
an Endometriose seit 28 Jahren.
Und nimmt dagegen Minolith ein.
Aber die Dosis ist eher nicht bekannt.
Sie hat auch keine Probleme
mit ihrer Regelblutung.
Sie berichtet, dass sie
keine Chance hat, schwanger zu sein.
Als sie Kind war,
ist bei ihnen eine Tonsilektomie
mit 10 Jahren durchgeführt.
Und eine Appendektomie mit 17 Jahren durchgeführt.
Und als Medikamenten
nehmen sie
ab und zu bald ihren Tropfen.
Also bei Bedarf.
Bei Frau Winter
sei eine Allergie bekannt.
Sie reagiert allergisch
auf braunes Pflaster.
Sie hat rote Pickelchen.
Sie reagiert mit rote Pickelchen
darauf.
Also Utikedia nehme ich an.
Und sie hat keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Sie rauche...
Sie hat mit Rauchen vor 3 Jahren aufgehört.
Aber vorher habe sie 12 Jahre lang
ungefähr 6 Zigaretten pro Tag geraucht.
Und sie trinke gelegentlich Alkohol.
Mit Drogen hat sie keinen Kontakt.
Mit Drogen habe sie keinen Kontakt.
Und als Sport
fährt sie Fahrrad gelegentlich.
Ihr Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Und ihre Scheiße an Amnesia
war unauffällig.
Ihr Vater leidet
an Gicht.
Und er ist vor einem Jahr
gestorben.
Und sie berichtete wahrscheinlich,
ist er wegen Alkoholabusus gestorben.
Blutvergiftung, also Alkoholabusus
verstorben.
Fachbegriff für Gicht?
Gicht, Fachbegriff.
Nein, also Gicht ist doch Fachbegriff.
Gibt es lateinische Namen?
Also das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Mir fällt ja gerade auch nicht ein.
Ich überlege gerade. Es heißt irgendwas...
Arthritis Ulrica oder Podolka?
Genau, Arthritis Ulrica.
Arthritis Ulrica.
Irgendwas mit Ulrica, das war mir klar.
Aber was da vorne weg war, wusste ich nicht mehr.
Ja, ok, jetzt habe ich mich auch daran erinnert.
Und ihre Mutter leidet an
Mobus Crohn.
Ihre Schwester ist gesund.
Soweit sie weiß.
Und sie ist eine ledige Frau, aber
sie lebt mit ihren Freunden zusammen.
Frau Winter habe keine Kinder.
Und sie arbeitet als
Schuhverkäuferin.
Ah ja, ok.
Und das war's.
Was ist denn jetzt ihre Vermutung?
Also
Ich habe eigentlich nicht etwas genaues ein.
Aber es kann ja auch
eine chronische Darmentzündung sein.
Also wie ihre Mutter Crohn oder
Ulcerative Colitz.
Und
sonst fällt mir nichts ein.
Also...
Denken Sie nochmal nach.
Unruhig und zitterig. Sie hat Gewicht abgenommen.
Sie hat Einschlafstörungen.
Sie kann Wärme nicht so gut vertragen.
Ja, also das kann auch eine...
Also sie kann auch in Wechseljahren sein.
Ja, das meine ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, gut, wäre auch eine Idee.
Und Unruhe.
Sie hat auch berichtet, dass sie Zitter habe.
Das kann eine hippochemische Attacke sein.
Ah, ok.
Aber ein Kollege hat eigentlich noch
eine gezielte Nachfrage gehabt.
Ja, es kann auch eine Hypothyrose sein.
Und ja.
Gut, also Zuckereingleisung haben wir gehabt.
Hypertereose haben wir gehabt.
Und sie haben gesagt,
als erste Diagnose haben Sie vermutet.
Was war das?
Also Morbis-Conschäddarm-Erkrankung.
Sie hat ja ab und zu Diarrho...
Prüfzelle. Ja, genau.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin denn diagnostisch?
Also ich würde sie erst
natürlich körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Also ich würde erst
natürlich eine Bauchuntersuchung machen.
Und ich werde auch die Schippdrüsen abtasten.
Ob Sie...
Ist es noch, wie Sie das machen?
Ja.
Ich soll mich hinter dem...
Ich soll mich hinter den Patienten
einstellen und nach vorne die
Schippdrüsen vorsichtig abtasten.
Und schlucken lassen.
Ich frage das deshalb,
weil das eine klassische Prüferfrage ist.
Fragen die gerne immer.
Gut.
Sie tasten die Schippdrüse ab.
Und was machen Sie noch?
Dann werde ich natürlich Blut abnehmen.
Und ich würde auch...
Das Herz
würde ich auch abhören.
Sie hat gesagt, dass Sie Herzrasen hatte, ne?
Natürlich würde ich auch eine LKG durchführen.
Damit ich ausschließen kann, ob eine
Herzkrankheit gibt.
Ja, und...
Ja, jetzt wollten Sie Blut abnehmen.
Und was bestimmen Sie im Blut?
Ich würde erst die entzündlichen Parameter
kontrollieren und natürlich die
T3, T4 und TSH-Hormone
messen.
Und natürlich auch
die Langzeit-Krank...
Langzeit-Glykose.
HbA1c.
HbA1c würde ich auch testen.
Bestimmen.
Und ich werde auch
eine Blutbild machen.
Gut.
Was wäre dann eine
weiterführende technische Untersuchung?
Also EKG machen wir noch unbedingt.
Und wir müssen
auch die Schilddrüsen-Sonographie machen.
Genau. Ja.
Falls es nötig ist,
können wir auch eine Biopsie nehmen.
Genau. Stimmt.
Wenn sich da was zeigt.
Ja.
Wenn es sich jetzt bestätigen würde,
dass die Patientin tatsächlich eine Schilddrüsenüberfunktion hat,
was wäre denn dann die Therapie?
Also für Schilddrüsen, also Hypothyrosen,
gibt es ja nur zwei Medikamente, die ich weiß.
Eine ist Propyl-Tio-Urasil.
Und andere fängt mit
E-M. Aber das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Also sie sind
Thyrostatika jedenfalls, ne?
Medikamente, die die Schilddrüse bremsen.
Ja, die Schilddrüsenhormone hemmen.
Genau. Und ich würde auch... Ja, Methamazol.
Es gibt ja nur zwei Medikamente.
Und ich würde auch
eine Betablocker verschreiben für die Herzrasen.
Stimmt. Ja, gute Idee.
Ja. Und ich würde...
Am ersten würde diese reichen.
Genau. Und das wäre dann
genau. Und dann muss man weiter gucken, ob das ausreicht,
oder ob sie nach wie vor... Ja.
Dann muss man eine weitere Therapie einplanen.
Ja. Was wären nächste Schritte, denkbare Schritte?
Also sie sollen nochmal
zur Kontrolle kommen.
Ja. Aber wenn sich dann zeigt, dass die
Beschwerden immer noch da sind, dass die
Thyrostatika alleine nicht helfen, was wäre dann
der denkbare Schritt?
Also es kann ja auch um eine Krebs, um eine
Tumor gehen.
Genau. Das wäre auch ein Gedanke, ja.
Aber was für Therapieoptionen
haben wir noch?
Also, chirurgische Therapie.
Dann die nächste, die hier gerade eben...
Ja, Jottherapie. Wenn wir...
Ja, können wir als chirurgische
Trösen entfernen.
Oder das, genau. Gut, ja, wunderbar.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich
auf dem Laufenden über Ihre
Untersuchungsergebnisse bei der Frau Winter.
Ja, gerne. Ja. Okay. Gut.
Also, Sie haben natürlich sprachlich so gut
wie überhaupt gar keine Probleme.
Das einzige, was mir aufgefallen ist,
obwohl Sie so super gut Deutsch
sprechen, Sie machen ständig äh, aber richtig
doll. Und das
merken Sie wahrscheinlich nicht. Wir machen das alle.
Das wissen Sie. Wir machen das auch alle
ziemlich häufig. Aber Sie machen es
wirklich extrem oft. Und das bräuchten Sie gar
nicht. Sie wissen ja alle Wörter. Sie brauchen diese
nicht. Ja. Heuchen Sie mal rein
in die Aufzeichnung von heute.
Ich weiß ja, ob Sie das ohne weiteres abhören
können. Ja, ich will können.
Wenn das geht, denn das ist wirklich
signifikant, wie oft Sie das machen.
Und damit zerstören Sie den guten Eindruck, den
Sie sonst machen mit Ihrer Sprache. Sie haben ja
überhaupt gar keine Sprachprobleme.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie
diese Standardformulierung haben Sie
ziemlich oft verwendet haben.
Sie haben ja praktisch Ihre ganze Liste praktisch abgeweidet.
Haben Sie das, haben Sie jenes, haben Sie
Verdauungsprobleme, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser?
Versuchen Sie da noch ein paar alternative
Formulierungen
sich anzugewöhnen einfach. Ja, ist Ihnen
aufgefallen, dass
haben Sie bemerkt, ja oder oder.
Okay. Okay. Also einfach, dass man das
noch mal ein bisschen
hat sich oder hat sich Ihr Gewicht
in letzter Zeit verändert. Nicht, dass haben Sie
Gewicht verloren oder haben Sie abgenommen.
Dass man noch mal irgendwie eine andere Formulierung
hat, damit es nicht ganz so eintönig ist.
Dann ein kleiner Klassiker.
Beim Vater haben Sie gefragt, wann hat er
gestorben? Nein, wann ist er gestorben?
Ja, okay, ich habe ich hat gesagt.
Ja, es ist aber
glaube ich echt ein Versehen gewesen.
Also wie gesagt, sprachlich macht
Ihnen ja keiner was vor.
Das Elb, das sollten Sie wirklich abstellen.
Versuchen Sie es. Lassen Sie sich mal,
lassen Sie sich von irgendjemanden, mit dem Sie
zusammenleben oder so aufzeichnen oder
oder unterbrechen. Hier, da hast du schon wieder gesagt.
Man merkt das ja nicht. Man macht das so unbewusst.
Und wie gesagt, wir alle machen das. Ich mache das auch.
Und wenn ich jetzt das reklamiere, dann nehme ich mich
sehr zusammen, dass ich versuche,
ein Äh dazwischen zu machen, weil ich es natürlich auch ständig
stelle. Ich habe verstanden, was Sie meine.
Ich muss mich sehr kontrollieren, um das nicht zu machen.
Nur bei Ihnen war es wirklich ziemlich krass. Das ist eigentlich schade.
Denn Sie reden ja wirklich fließend perfekt,
wunderbar, fast ohne Akzent.
Also alles gut. Augenblick.
Eine Sache, ja,
was keiner gefragt hat,
das ist die Geschichte mit dem Klosgefühl
im Hals. Wenn man also Richtung Schilddrüse denkt,
könnte man das fragen. Ist Ihnen das aufgefallen,
dass Ihnen das Schlucken manchmal schwerfällt oder so?
Aber Sie waren auf der Schiene mit der
Schilddrüse waren Sie gar nicht.
Aber das wäre, wenn man in diese Richtung
dann irgendwie nachfragt, das wäre noch möglich.
Da hätte möglicherweise die Patientin auch noch
einen Hinweis, dass Sie nicht
nachfragt werden. Aber wenn man da nicht nachgefragt wird,
sagt man das auch nicht.
Man gewöhnt sich ja an sowas.
Man merkt, dass man beim Schlucken mit einem
so ein bisschen Widerstand hat. Das ist jetzt halt so.
Das sind ja alles Sachen, die immer so langsam
sich entwickeln. Und ja, wann fängt es an,
dass man es registriert und dass man sagt,
hey, da ist was nicht in Ordnung.
Das ist ja eigentlich so eine Schwelle,
wo man sagt, jetzt merke ich, dass was unangenehm ist.
Mehr kann ich eigentlich zu Ihrer Anamnese nicht sagen.
Sie haben die ja natürlich top gemacht.
Top gefragt und top Präsentation.
Natürlich war es die Huberterrore.
Ich dachte schon, der Fall wäre
ein bisschen zu banal und zu einfach.
Weil die Spur, die gelegt ist, ja eigentlich sehr breit ist.
Aber ja, es gibt doch Herausforderungen.
Wunderbar.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Südmann.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Wegen Anamnesebogen.
Wir haben Fragen
über, haben Sie oder ist Ihnen
Allergien bekannt? Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Zum Beispiel, wie kann man
erklären zwischen
Allergien und Unverträglichkeit
Unterschiede?
Vielleicht der Patient fragt,
was ist die Unterschied
zwischen Allergien und Unverträglichkeit?
Wie können wir
erzählen?
Auch in der Simulation frage ich ja manchmal
ein bisschen verständnislos.
Ich habe doch gesagt, ich habe keine anderen Allergien.
Eigentlich geht es ja bei
Unverträglichkeiten
in der Regel um Nahrungsmittelunverträglichkeiten.
Und Allergien, das sind
diese exogenen Sachen,
wie zum Beispiel Pollen
oder Hausstaubmilben.
Das sind die Sachen, die wir
einatmen, die wir eben auch andereweise
in Kontakt kommen oder auch Hautkontaktallergien.
Es gibt Leute, die
Medikamentallergie,
Chemialergie.
Ja, also klar, das sind
Kontaktallergien oder eben
speziell Medikamentenallergien,
die ja häufig
auch sehr dramatisch verlaufen.
Wobei ich da zum Beispiel
auch nicht sagen kann,
wo ist da die Unverträglichkeit
und wo ist da die Allergie?
Ich denke mal, die Unverträglichkeit
ist eigentlich eher im Bereich
tatsächlich dann der Ernährung.
Gibt es irgendwelche Nahrungsmittel,
die Sie überhaupt nicht vertragen?
Und dann kommt natürlich immer der Klassiker mit der Milch.
Ja, für die Laktoseintoleranz.
Dann kommt die Nachfrage nach der Glutenunverträglichkeit.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Sie Brot oder Nudeln
nicht besonders gut vertragen können?
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch
diese Reizdarmengeschichten,
dass Leute eben erklären,
wenn ich rohes Gemüse esse,
dann kriege ich ganz schnell Blehungen und Durchfall
und solche Geschichten.
Aber ich glaube,
das ist vielleicht so am ehesten diese Unterscheidung.
Medikamente, chemische Stoffe,
Sachen, die wir einatmen
oder die wir mit der Haut aufnehmen
auf der einen Seite.
Da haben wir diese Pflasterallergie nicht wahr.
Übrigens, Frau Dr. Sahid, Ihnen sehr dankbar,
dass Sie das mit der Allergie auf braunes Pflaster
haben Sie sehr schön gesagt.
Denn manche Kollegen
machen da so eine braune Pflasterallergie draus.
Und das gibt es nicht.
Eine braune Allergie haben wir nicht.
Aber es gibt eine Pflasterallergie auf braunes Pflaster.
Das sind diese Sachen,
die von außen an uns herangetragen werden.
Und das andere sind die Lebensmittel, die wir essen,
die andere Leute gut vertragen
und die mir Schwierigkeiten machen
aufgrund meines speziellen Enzymsystems.